sixteen
was hat die cdu dagegen dass 16-jährige
wählen dürfen die volljährigkeit beginnt
bei uns eine bundesrepublik achte ab dem
achtzehnten lebensjahr danach kann man
entsprechend wählen danach kann man
entsprechend verträge abschließen und
autofahren sie hatten auch einfach sagen
können dass ich schiss haben weil die
jungen die cdu einfach gar nicht wählen
das ist ihre persönliche meinung und die
sehr unterstellen es konkret zu sagen
ich für ein öffentlich rechtliches
rundfunksystem finde ich das schon sehr
anmaßend was ich sagen anmache top wenn
sie jemandem sagen der vom volke gewählt
ist dass er schiss hat ich sag mal ganz
einfach die haben wir nicht so wir haben
eine klare auffassung dann geht die düse
das besser
wenn ich solche journalisten höre wie
sie ja
ist ja immer so gut drauf eigentlich
geschäfte staatskanzlei das ganze ja das
war eine sehr formale begründung ja also
ich dich so so ist hat darauf warum
wollen sie denn hier in hessen
verhindern dass jugendliche schon mit 16
wählen dürfen das wollen wir nicht
verhindern dass unterstützen wer aber es
geht immer um politische mehrheiten
aber wenn sie das unterstützen dann
könnten sie hat den antrag der spd
unterstützen auch oder seit wann
unterstützt man oppositionsanträge wenn
man in einer regierungsfraktion ist dann
könnten sie als grüne jahren eigenen
antrag einbringen das machen wir auf
bundesebene aber die grünen sind doch
sogar von jungen menschen
überproportional gewählt worden
das stimmt das recht hat die cdu
deswegen angst wir sind ja unter uns
also wenn sie nicht fragen ja
aber das darf ich eigentlich nicht im
fernsehen sagen ja okay wir können sich
einfach wechseln in dem moment wäre das
okay dass er okay
das ist willi auf dem pulli von theo
theo will wählen aber weiß er auch wie
das gerät also du glaubst wirklich du
hast schon die geistige reife dass du
dein kreuz machen kannst ich habe es
nicht die geistige reife eines 80
jährigen aber zumindest habe ich die
geistige reife für mich mit den
einzelnen parteiprogramm sorgfältig zu
befassen und
faktenbasiert eine entscheidung zu
treffen und ich denke das können auch
die meisten in meinem alter wie wäre es
mit dem kompromiss du darfst wählen aber
nur die cdu
dann las ich
so was sagen denn oma und opa wenn die
enkelchen auf einmal wählen wollen es
wollen aber ja immer mehr 16-jährige das
ist richtig wir wollen auch viel und es
wird nicht alles in die tat umgesetzt
rechnung endlich fühle ich mich wieder
wie bei meinen eltern zu hause am
abendbrottisch es ist wieder die gute
alte zeit ist sie haben mich
angesprochen oder solange du hier unter
meinem tisch wählst wird hier nicht
gewählt und ganz gute idee in dem moment
die jugendlichen und tam haben pfeffer
und power außerdem so viele fdp gewählt
haben das war
richtig dass eine gewisse
lebenserfahrung um wählen zu können
braucht man die wirklich braucht man
wirklich sicher nie hat man ab 18 haben
sie das gemacht als die 18 dadurch
strömte sie die lebenserfahrung auf
einmal ja ich habe alles viel besser
verstanden haben das weiß ich heute
nicht
ich möchte erstmal das die politik bevor
sie in die politik geht also die jungen
politiker eine ausbildung machen ihre
eigene wohnung haben ihr salzfass
auffüllen ich weise alle politiker im
prinzip immer nur von schul kommen war
da einer mal dabei deren handwerker war
der richtig was geschafft oder werden
salz aufgefüllt
vorschlag zur güte ich hätte da eine
idee
ich bin dafür dass man ab 75 nicht mehr
wählen darf dagegen es ist nicht
unmöglich schwert zu wählen sagen wir 80
wer das in kompromissen ein welt kein
grund brauchen ist wie alt haben sie
noch vor zu werden und das ok ab 100
nicht mehr wählen
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich